Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to Zombs.io or Zombsio or
ZOMBZIO or ZOMZIO And this one was interesting because SUPPOSEDLY
And again, I don't know, I'm talkin' out my ass here, I don't really know - start off by gathering some resources - but SUPPOSEDLY
*hitting noises by Mark*
I'm gonna REALLY give it to this TREEE here but SUPPOSEDLY this one is different BECAUSE
you actually build a base here and you gotta build it and try to survive against a zombie attack
So I don't know what that means in the long run, but hopefully it's gonna mean something okay. Once you're - now you're ready to place
down your gold stash. Once you establish your base, Zombies will start spawning each night
OOOHHH
OHHH
Dayumm!
Okay. I don't know if I'm ready though. Maybe I should get more supplies!
*more weird hitting noises*
Mmmm, gold stash. Okay, we're gonna do this. Right.
HUUUAAHHH
Can I - okay I'm standing on that one, sorry
HAAHH. You're ready to start building your defenses. Start by using five wood you gathered and place an Arrow Tower from toolbar Below
Okey-Dokey then
haaa?
Okay! OH HI OH I didn't know! I wasn't ready for thiiis! I was not ready!
oh God okay all right all right all right all right okay, okay, okay, okay?
Okay. Gold mine! I don't know - it - oh gold mine okay all right
I don't know how I got dad but okay cannon tower. I don't have wood, or stone but I can
Build More Gold Mines Which is always a good guess I have
No idea what I'm Doing I probably Shouldn't have Space everything out like this now that I'm Thinking about it but
Well i'm getting Gold I think?
I'm trapped Wait I've Just Fucked Myself I have Bones owned Myself I can't move I
Boxed Myself in I'm an asshole Let me Try this again them Job
No, we're Gonna arrive again?
Oh Those Guys are on wave 100 they're Pretty good at Whatever they do but
I don't know if They've Met Me and how good I am at
Slapping This Tree With This Bush With, my rock stick B I'm good at hit Rock stick
Oh, yeah, I don't need to worry about night I don't even Have a base belt so I don't think i'm Left
I'm just Gonna Stay Here and Build as Best I can
Hopefully it's okay
I don't know if it will be but I
Have got Hope in my heart and that's Usually what Powers me Through These Adventures even in The Face of death of
Zombie Bite I'm gonna be fine
Believe Myself
Okay I think That's Probably Enough okay i'm going to be Old Dears Now and I'm not going to be so Stupid about it
I'm going to build
On a building's Actually A bit more out
That way I least have some
Equidistance Old Room
To Build Those
Then i Can fill These
Right There
That's Good I Bet There's a way to unbuild if There's a way to build there's got
To, be a way to unveil doing ping Pong, okay I got those I don't know if That Step for me but I got it
Woo that's what I Spend my go, oh?
That Makes Sense
Yeah
okay alright
That's Beta I
Don't want to do Any of that I like to do it Myself
Maybe I'm Gonna get Another Pickaxe Alright up Graham a pickaxe Boiling Point Point Point to you doubles I likey I'm
Like who are you get out of here you know you're not A good player I don't need A not a good player in my
Area I need a good player maybe I don't know how you Would Help me Or any Capacity die ooh death to you
Oh i i have I have A bit of a problem here, oh, oh, oh, Boy, oh Boy
I didn't anticipate them Coming from who, ah
I am Bones They get my Shit, oh they bashed up my gold Mines
Farming Things, oh
Hey I'm on the leaderboard hey?
Really low on the Leaderboard but Liam bear up now up just drop the spot, okay um
The Bottom Nevermind I'm not on the Leaderboard at 15. I don't know the Band's
We're Gonna have a lot of bam's walls Would be smart
Why
Don't I have walls that Seems like something that I need I
Don't know if That helps Me in Any way Or if They're Evil men Are They even able to
Hit Through that the Fasces Pero La ola okay, they can't fire over the wall that's good to know hey
Hey Come on Now Come on Silly Jim Get out of There?
Well i mean i'm doing something Can I upgrade These then the last Thing I know you Can, okay so I need Stain
Why are you not go Faster go Faster get that Stone Get it Dirty Grab it with your claw, oh stab it
I'M an Upgrade you Bad Boys what Can I not Upgrade you Bad Girls you
Seem like Something that I would be able to Upgrade you Bad Boys you Bad Boys why are you not Afraid
About This is a load of Bullshit I am Quest
Doodlee Doodlee Doodlee Doodlee doing okay got that good I Didn't build a door but
I don't can't even Build the core Gonna do Report Give me your Shit Refuel
I don't know what that's Gonna do, oh, hey, We got Incoming
We i ain't Coming good
Okay, don't take my gold you got I just Because I've Got to build something doesn't mean that you get to Jump in There who
You Have Weapons why, do you have Weapons hey, hey, hey, hey eat a bunch of Pickaxe in the face you fool i asked
okay
There's This Door Work that's how that Work I don't know if that how that Work I play Stores and Hopefully that's okay yes?
Okay, something that I can go through I don't know why I didn't build it on the Outside of These Towers here but
Maybe it's Because again I'm Stupid and I don't know what I'm doing so I've got kind of a little bit of a base Here
Because I'm going to christen it as
Castle Markiplier Is
Stupid
I'm going to call it the Market castle Because I'm unoriginal and I'm egotistical and I like the sound of my Own Name Doodly-Doo Doodly-doo
Whacking at a tree until I get a lot of wood now Sch doodly doo
Dearly To earn This Tree Up real good now hey fuck you get away
From my Base don't you dare Come
Over Here I'm going to go Through my door I can't Upgrade Anything Walking on Up I don't know why life Is alive, oh?
Upgrade that, oh
Oh i can Upgrade everything else Now Made you refuel you repeal real Good
okay
So the most important thing is to
Upgrade as You Go I'm starting to get Bang if This I get it I love tower defense Games I love Just Base Building Stuff
Even if it's Mundane like this Now I don't know how it Applies
When Everyone Else Is Involved in The Game here Because there are A lot of People errand Marking Move it's not the only one I'm
Server but I'm Gonna Preview Bellboys so I've Been lying, don't click These Bad Boys for a while
Oh you Bad Boys a pretty you - oh you Bad Boys, oh I need more Gold hey you Upgraded Bad Boys you
Make more Gold now okay come, on you Make more Gold Faster
oh Those Look so good huh things Look a little
Damaged but That's okay?
I got my Melee Towers they are the ones That are Really Gonna give it to them that's a good Bad Boy
These are Good Bad Boys here There's A lot of Good Bad Boy going on Here
Upgrade Upgrade Upgrade Upgrade Upgrade Upgrade Annan's Upgrade Upgrade, Suite Upgrade Upgrade Upgrade Upgrade Upgrade, nah None Up wood
Oh Jeez These, walls ain't I gotta Upgrade all These
Walls all were you Kidding me I'm Gonna do it but I'm gonna be Angry About it, oh
We're Gonna Shit the kind of Shit that I gotta deal With, oh?
As if They don't know who I am
Right Now That I've Slapped Gold inside my walls They're Definitely aren't going to be People to come out and kill me
Well so they, don't seem like Zombies They're using Weapons and Seem Awfully intelligent and Organized and I mean They?
May Be Coming Knocking at my door Dingdong at night but that doesn't Mean That They're not
Super Smart About What They're doing swings wrong, oh that is A lot of Those assholes
What am I
What did Barely on Number seven?
Oh God I'm on leaderboard now but I apparently I'm not going to stay There Because Ever One Thing is going Horribly Wrong I'm Guessing
That I should be A Lot more Upgraded than I actually am Right now Maybe I should Make double Thick walls
That Seems like something that I should do well now that I got, some wood stop Swinging stop it stop
Why are you swinging so much what do you got so swing for like this Pain
Don't you know that the end With Zombies until you, die I'm going to build more Walls Cuz why not, oh they broke Through
Oh, well that's a Damn Shame alright, well Plug that hole Up real Good
I don't think I got enough to Upgrade all These Bad Boys but hey you know
What's Probably good Enough to Repel Evil Zombie Jack I mean, well sold that one Didn't Mean to but all right here We go?
There We go that's good you don't need to be There all right cool, I'm a build more Doors I like good
Ok, well that Looks Bad but I Guess it's Gonna have to do right do Have enough to Upgrade This I sure do all right
I did that now
Glad There was A klaxon Horn that, was making That all Sound Really Authentic and cool
We did that now I'm getting more Gold so exponential Growth Is good I good either way I'm Gonna Keep hitting this Rock because that's
The First Thing I did When I came
Into This World so I see last Thing I want to do when I get dragged out Kicking Screaming by Zombie night game soon
Like Winter
Have i died yet am I dead is everything dead yeah Probably I'm Gonna go with Probably
Hey Im Number 6, on Leader board the other People are Still Up in the Millions but at
Least i'm Making A good school, oh hi, who the fuck are you i thought you were an enemy Real quick
Oh my god I've got
A whole Bunch of other People here why are they here I don't know what do you want to do with me hey
Get out, of here what's that hey you?
Asshole you're A ball come on to me hey fuck you
What are you doing yeah you better back off yeah that's right he's Dead Now I think I killed him that's what you get for
Smick Smack in My wall don't do that is the Lesson you learn, don'ts Make Smack
We don't belong and then you won't be dead did Understood and I made Myself Absolutely not clear hey
What are you doing in fact did you get out of here I'm Enjoying my okay, well you got
Buzz Coming your Way for Summary I don't know why but you do you really do hey, dom what do ya
Is that A boss not A big Boss, oh God get away, from my gold hey, hey, no no, no
No, no, no, no, no no
Get dead, oh got it oh God he's gettin my stash not my stash
NOOOOO NOOO AHHHHHHHHHHH
That's what he was Waiting for oh, no he's Dead - okay, well alright then alright
Respawn, oh
I'm Swinging I'm Swinging back Into life okay, well I guess I'm back Now I thought that
Was gonna be The end of it but I did go - Bound at the beginning Zone that is the thing that happens, okay
Why I'm gonna go and See if There's other Players Around Everywhere?
Oh the infected ask to join me I Didn't even See that in the chat because my face was Covering it Oops Oopsy Poopsy?
That was my Bad Oopsie, oh I could have gone on?
Expeditions I could Have Bought a sperg Gonna Bought A sweet Spur and then smack you in the foot, no
Damaged and Not Get I could have Bought more all that Would have been Great - No i didn't know that all there's More
Complexity to This Game Whose Job I'm Just okay. I don't know what happened, oh?
Dog, well This Is broken, okay, no no I am broke the game Nice Approach and got to stab my way back to my basic
Stabbed Get stabbed You want to do they got give Me Anything, oh they give Me Tokens
I don't know what to do With Tokens but at. Least Those are A thing can get Stabbed
Watch the Goose-Girl
Street it's Death Rockets can do you
Got my basil you get Stabbed it's Dead but are the Double Air walls Work to him all These Guys Got Stabbed Into Oblivion
They Didn't See This Abaddon's Coming, okay all right, We got pretty good?
Operation Going on Here I'm pretty Proud of This everyone's done a great Job here There's
No one here but you know someone has to be my friend and Then I forgotten I said no Apparently I'm an A-hole
So Anyway that has Been I'm Stuck okay There, We go alright
We're I don't think that's working Correctly I'm Lagging A bit here but that is Zombie
Oh so that was Pretty fun I actually Enjoyed that A bit I can See if This?
was a more
Populated Server and I Would stop Jumping all over the place this could be A lot of fun if it was super super
Scoop or dense so thank you everybody so much for Watching I hope you guys Enjoyed This one There's Numerous other io Games in
Website Alone There's Just I can even Show you the home Page here if I leave my thing there's Just
Guard Akio Wild deal Flappy a blocker game, Cuz App go eat bomb hi
Squad Dark Nova Spin vo I don't want evan want to go near that one and then Moomoo io which I've Heard
Also was a good one Stress so if you know Any of These the Floor is Lava
Anyway so there's a whole bunch of other Ones Here if You guys want to See Any of These
Played
Let me Know There's Just tons and tons of These so go to this Website if You want play some free multiplayer games Thank you
Everybody so much for Watching Let me know You thought it down the Comments Below Thanks
Han for Watching and as always I will see you in the next Video
Buh-bye